welcome to this video playing playing no
I play barge and Men margin men from
from Sweden
okay let's play Queens and yeah and just
like God did the World Championship
AHA Bishop is excrete 84 yeah didn't
even know that this move is existing
okay maybe just play for me it's normal
with g3 the plot with a three okay I'm
interesting so no maybe not they might
let you form
hmm interesting I wanted to play quicker
but this is not possible now
t5 is really a problem yeah maybe I need
to do that not really what I wanted you
know the sisters make some sense the
Queen here okay I mean not that black
isn't a terrible situation here but it
wasn't what I was hoping for I expected
to get maybe
can I go Knight you for here too to get
something going with this bishop maybe
maybe yeah that what's with Knight e5
coming
maybe my position is really too shaky to
do any anything like that if I take on
c3
tigran c3
5894 seems to be seems to be playable
bishop the eighth night a for Bishop e7
rukia's should be okay really at least
okay so probably be takes Queen e7 and
then I have some threat here on e2
Queen a6 I go queen is seven none should
be okay as well what exactly may be
Queen before here Queen B form
aha okay I did a very sloppy calculation
as usual before it's interesting maybe I
can play C five against that okay so
he's just giving up this pawn
interesting yeah okay I'm going to take
it and then possibly Queen to see for
Queen should be five if it is a tech
[Music]
yeah yeah sure it's not like I'm in
great shape e I know it's a it's still a
very tricky situation okay going to be
fired
yeah nevertheless I am I guess
[Music]
should I go yeah I should play that
really as long as it's still possible I
should play that Wow this far for 96 if
I go here is going to take it then 96 I
guess 96
but I can't go just here yeah why not
I mean okay I understand that there are
dangerous but still tricky I think he
can just go back to the three and has
heaven he has very good compensation it
was C for at some point or night before
but it seems that no it's not looking
for more going to d7 or should I just
hack this off it's nothing you like to
do but because the light squares are now
even weaker it
[Music]
okay I don't know about rupee one maybe
it is good but at least the c4 move
isn't so easily playable then okay might
be a dia what a great move I can go
Bishop f5 which is really problematic
check that that one maybe as well I can
take and activate the Queen on the fifth
rank maybe this is better
I mean activate is a big word but maybe
you know I think I think things could
have been even worse
[Music]
[Music]
yeah this I understand but he's also he
also has some problems here in this
position especially with the deponent
it's not clear what if the bishop here
is so great okay let's go in there time
warning c5 not clear I can play d5 maybe
but okay after came only after 90 and I
only have 49 seconds
check-check
[Music]
[Music]
my night is going to be activated
oh yes so take it after which t5 is
problem okay
[Music]
[Music]
check check check check
[Music]
game draw just a draw I mean okay if I
was lost yeah it's ID Lots large parts
of the game but then he just gave me the
rook and I mean it's possible certainly
to do a twenty seconds but it yeah I
didn't
I should probably really just take this
I didn't want to want him to give it and
it didn't I didn't like the pawns yeah
mmmm
look PA I should probably play at some
point but it's not so easy here with ten
seconds I'm really not yeah well the the
opening here was was funny that the
status have a look here this idea this
is I can go maybe here
no Bishop the ages good okay rook e8 is
the computer move that
funny check check check with the draw
okay I didn't see any of that so he but
he gave up this and yeah I'm really OC
for now would have been strong had this
hope this whole position is very shaky
it was a risky business here white is
probably just winning him it's not good
okay right here he really has a
substantial compensation check I'm not
really sure about all this I think here
maybe with some good moves I can somehow
untangle but it is not easy 24 is better
than this Jan yeah yeah yeah I'm in huge
trouble
yeah okay well somehow I have won this
rook but couldn't manage timewise okay
thanks for watching